vous avez peut-être assisté à leur
déménagement c'était en octobre dernier
au pied du château de Blois 3 statues
monumentales qui dormaient dans les
caves du monument depuis plus de 80 ans
retrouvait alors à la lumière du jour
elles étaient déplacées pour être
confiées à une restauratrice
d'Indre-et-Loire si moi plus tard les
statues encrassaient mais classés on
retrouve leur beauté originelle on voit
ça avec les la Turquie
[Musique]
plus que des petites retouches pour ses
colosses de plâtre c'est l'heure du
ponçage pour Charlemagne l'une des
dernières étapes après de longues heures
de dépoussiérage nettoyage renforcement
du socle et bouchage de la sculpture
elles étaient tâchées couverte de
poussière de crasse ancrée de tâches
et elles étaient aussi également très
abîmées très altérée par le fait que
elles étaient conservées dans un endroit
qui était humide cet endroit c'était les
caves du château royal de Blois les
trois statues déstockées pendant plus de
80 ans et ce jusqu'à l'automne dernier
depuis leur sortie elles sont entre les
mains de Delphine pour se refaire une
petite beauté elles ont retrouvé leur
teint d'origine
les sculptures sont imposantes plus de 2
mètres de haut à restaurer un travail
étalé sur cinq mois et qui touche à sa
fin avant leur retour à Blois on fait
les tests de repositionnement des têtes
sur le reste des corps et on complète
des zones de de
manque pour pouvoir les réinstaller
définitivement ensuite au château
Saint-Louis Charlemagne et Louis XII
sculpté par François Delestre sont
classés au monument historiques depuis
2017 ils seront de retour pas dans les
caves cette fois mais bien dans
l'ensemble du château à partir de début
juin
[Musique]